on devrait donc en savoir plus plus tard
dans la soirée
claude evin avait rendu visite ce matin
aux infirmières en grève à saint nazaire
en province le mouvement le sait a donné
au fil des jours quelques signes
d'effritement ainsi à sablé dans la
sarthe
la grève avait été levée au début de la
semaine alors quel est l'état d'esprit
des infirmières qui ont repris le
travail
daniel duigou est aller le vérifier sur
place depuis lundi dernier les cinquante
cinq infirmières de l'hôpital de sable
et ont repris le travail ainsi que les
aides soignantes et les aides
anesthésistes depuis le début du conflit
il ya tout juste trois semaines
les infirmières avaient décidé la grève
tenu des assemblées générales et
participé à des manifestations
régionales
mais depuis les propositions
gouvernementales de vendredi dernier
elle estime que poursuivre la grève
c'est faire plus de mal que de bien au
niveau de coordination sarthe nous avons
arrêté et décidé d'arrêter la grève dans
la mesure où les soins ne pouvait
étaient obligés de se faire pour le pour
le bienfait du malade
donc on a tous décidé d'arrêter la grève
mais par contre nous allons faire une
information au niveau de la population
que ce soit au mans à sablé à mamers à
la ferté-bernard pour informer les gens
sur notre profession nous sommes quand
même à sable est une petite ville
consciente en tant qu'infirmière que les
patients que nous soignons sont des gens
vous croisant dans la rue tous les jours
et pour eux nous avons décidé de
reprendre le travail l'ambiance dans cet
hôpital de province qui a été construit
il ya à peine dix ans est sans doute
très différente de celle des grandes
structures parisiennes et des hôpitaux
des grandes villes en particulier la
proximité entre soignants et malades est
nettement plus grande
bon est ce qu'elles peuvent obtenir plus
maintenant je ne crois pas dans
l'immédiat il ya des problèmes qui sont
des problèmes qui ressorte du cadre de
la loi il faut que la loi soit modifiée
les infirmières ont cependant décidé de
rester en contact avec la coordination
nationale de participer demain samedi à
la manifestation à paris et d' informer
les malades sur les raisons du conflit
elles se tiennent prêtes à refaire grève
si nécessaire